we're going to go to a story that is
controversial
it has made headlines across the country
um ari nagel has fathered over 100
children
in just over a decade
now he's not in a relationship with any
of the mothers uh he's an independent
sperm doter delivering uh directly to
his recipients
um we'll get into that in a minute
um
he does it all for free
so before we hear from him i would love
to hear from some of the women
who say that he's changed their lives by
giving them a chance to be a mother
hi i'm lee i'm a mom to an amazing
seven-year-old son named elijah hi my
name is shamiga i'm a mother to an
amazing one-year-old named germany my
name is yvonne harrison and i am the
proud mom of a beautiful loving
fantastic seven-year-old zoe doll
harrison i always wanted to have a child
but i never knew exactly how
that would look and how i would start a
family especially when i was in a
same-sex relationship in marriage just
me by myself and i always knew that i
just wanted to be a mother i was like
you know what i'm in my 30s i'm not
getting any younger i need to go ahead
and do this there was ivf iui
adoption
and then there was sperm donation with a
known donor or anonymously through a
sperm bank i went through a number of
failed attempts i mean i'm talking about
astronomical amounts of money that we
spent it was just too much money for me
and then i started googling uh you know
free donors known sperm donors and
already popped up
so we were quite nervous when we first
decided to meet up with ari i found a
couple of the other moms that he had
helped and i was just looking at their
pages on facebook and i'm like
this is this is real we met at uh asian
restaurant actually in new york city
immediately from the moment we sat down
at the table it was an instant
connection we just knew
once we met him that it just clicked and
that he was the one that we wanted to be
our daughter i feel like since my
daughter has been born me and ari have
developed a tight-knit friendship she
speaks to ari at least two or three
times a week we actually invite him over
for dinner quite frequently now he is
family to us family comes in different
types different styles different shapes
ari has been probably the best thing
that could ever happen to me my wife and
my daughter i wouldn't trade it for the
world if i had to do it all over again
10 times i'd do it all over again 10
times she is truly a blessing
i am so excited to have this
conversation now have you two ever met
before uh backstage yeah backstage last
night we said hi at the hotel
well that was oversized everybody said
family comes in many forms
um all right lee you have your uh
seven-year-old son yep so how much does
he know about his biological father um
elijah my son he knows everything he's
known it since he was born we always
were honest
we wanted him to know everything and
grow up with it being his norm so
nothing was a surprise
so we've been really honest with him and
he
knows everything he'll explain it to
people who ask he'll be like i'll
explain the story and he'll tell them so
he knows everything okay shamika
um explain how this process worked with
ari
i am i reached out to ari and i had a
conversation with him but it took me
maybe about a year to actually start the
process but um
went to the bronx zoo
and voila
what's voila
i met him in the bronx zoo met him in
the bathroom
he did his thing
came and brought it out to me and then i
did my thing and that was it so
you did with ari what they call like a
hand-off process in a soft cup
okay um
so
tell us about like is there a community
after the process you're able to
conceive you're able to give birth
now what where do you go from there it's
funny because when we started when we um
started trying to conceive elijah and we
had him was
years ago obviously my son's seven now
so we started this about eight nine
years ago ari wasn't in the tabloids in
the media you know we never even heard
of anybody conceiving a family this way
we started wanting to help other moms
kind of navigate through it and not be
so scared and through that we just
started developing a family a community
um
a facebook group we meet you know we
talk we help other moms and it's really
become like its own
community yeah do you think that you
know
either of you would be mothers today
without ari
no no i mean
i like to think
i was supposed to have a child and i
would have it in some way
but it wouldn't be elijah it wouldn't be
our child ari wouldn't be its father he
wouldn't have these hundred siblings you
know he wouldn't have yeah i mean
you know i'd be interested in how he
explains that story
he actually has to his class
the teacher emailed us and said you know
i want to let you know elijah's amazing
in class he's so sweet but you know i
don't want him to be lying he thinks he
has 100 siblings i'm like no it's true
and she's like i'm sorry i think it came
up because she wanted them to draw a
family tree and they gave a paper and
he's like you have a poster board
he's like it's not gonna fit
[Music]